hey you guys movie retrospective time
once again and we're doing some more
real old [ __ ] going back to the 60s yeah
because i feel like we like i said you
guys seem to
when i put 50s and 60s movies in the
polls like those usually get the most
votes
and i do kind of feel like that's
probably a direction we want to go in
uh going forward a little bit just
because there's a lot of un you know
kind of movies that we haven't done like
from those eras and i feel like we
should do because we've done like [ __ ]
tons of stuff from them
in the market too there's not a lot of
people talking about those yeah that's
what i'm saying and this one uh dementia
13 is one this one does have several
reviews uh probably mostly because uh it
was directed by francis ford coppola in
one of his uh very very first films uh
so there is some of that but this movie
kind of falls into the same category as
you know carnival of souls or night of
night of living dead um that because of
like accidents with legal [ __ ] like fell
into the public domain so this movie
usually turns up if you get you know how
you used to buy like those dvds or
blu-rays of like you know 50 horror
movies like from the 1960s and usually
this is one of the ones that's on there
and that's because it's uh you know in
the public domain now in 2017 though uh
francis ford coppola actually
uh oversaw a a
new blu-ray release like a special
edition that was all like redone and
everything like that and he actually did
a director's cut which weirdly is
shorter than the uh theatrical cut
because he took out some stuff that
roger corman had put in there that he
didn't really like uh and this movie's
pretty short to start with i think we
saw the theatrical cut although it did
look nice we watched it on 2b you can
watch it for free on pluto as well um so
i'm not sure if that's the same version
that was on blu-ray but it said it was
74 minutes 75 minutes and i think the
director's cut is 69 minutes it's a
decent movie it's a weird movie because
it's in between eras it has
60s style acting it feels very stagey
like a play but then it has a lot of
elements of slasher and kind of it
cutting edge type stuff like
you can tell it's trying to top psycho
um which it kind of does in a way it's
kind of impressive for a low budget
movie pretty well made i mean for 1963
well the thing about it francis ford
coppola um this actually like i said
technically was not his first movie
because he'd actually made a couple
nudie pictures like before this one but
this was kind of his first i guess you
want to call it like legitimate movie
like you know sexploitation movies are
movies too but i'm just saying that he
doesn't usually uh put those on his
resume i guess but yeah so this is like
the first one that he actually got to
direct that was like a legitimate movie
i guess if you want to say has a good
cast you'll recognize the people uh one
of the main one of the leads is the guy
who played
the alien child in the old star trek the
classic ones the one where he's dressed
up like napoleon and playing with kirk
and spock and then it turns out later
he's basically like a q
and then it turns out
it is ridiculous he is his parents show
up he was always sorry this is our child
no mom i'm gonna still play you know
he's in it and he does a good job he
does he was yeah william campbell i
think that actually his name is i think
he was in a couple of the uh star trek
star treks yeah he played a couple
different roles in it but the one he's
mostly remembered for is basically a q a
q child which is you know if you know
next generation or cues and he's like
he's like a
god-like alien being that can just
control reality and if
it captures the enterprise and starts
playing with the crew like toys and
doing little war games he's dressed up
like napoleon and [ __ ]
and they don't know how to deal with it
then eventually his parents showed oh
i'm sorry he's just a child you know
we'll give you back to the ship it was a
good episode but he's in it does a good
job and then he has that other guy who's
that though creepy
what was he from patrick mcgee he was in
uh well he was in a [ __ ] down this time
a ton of movies probably most people
recognize him from a clockwork orange
orange he's the guy who's the typewriter
you know yeah that ends up in the
wheelchair that gets attacked yeah i
mean he was in i think he was in some of
roger corman's other movies too was he
not uh wasn't he in some of his po
pictures i feel like he was in mask of
the red death but
i think he might have been so yeah he
worked a lot with uh roger corman back
in the day and then there's uh three or
four cute 60s chicks in it to get you to
watch somebody luanna anders who's kind
of like the man we'll get into sort of
like the main character uh at least at
the beginning of the movie uh she
actually i think she was either maybe
was dating jack nicholson at the time
um or no maybe that was the other woman
that was in this one of the two chicks
was dating jack nicholson and was in
uh easy rider i think yeah but it might
not have been the main one like at the
beginning it might have been the other
one the girl that played kane all these
people had careers you know i mean they
all ended up being something you know
they might have been forgotten but this
is a long time ago this is the 60s you
know but if you're into movies and old
tv series you'll recognize them and it's
set in a real irish castle it is it
doesn't have real irish people in it all
the time but i don't think there are any
real life some of the background
characters are actual irish people um
but yeah most of them even if they're
supposed to be irish they're usually
americans although they do have like a
little bit of a line in there where it
said like the because all the main guys
that are in it are supposed to be this
irish family but they're saying oh they
got educated in america so presumably
they lost their access so um it's it's
you don't have to worry about funky sets
or anything it's on location and it's a
good location it's creepy looking yeah
that's actually i think it's called
house castle like outside of dublin and
you're gonna see some uh dead bodies and
weird and guess like preserved bodies
and
weird [ __ ] the opening sequence shows a
dead body kind of artistically decaying
underneath the water it looks really
cool it's creepy
um just brace yourself it's 60s you know
i mean it's got 60s acting it's like the
star trek episode and it was very
inexpensive to make which we'll get into
in a little bit
but they're trying to do kind of like
psycho and like take it up a couple
notches and uh it's weird
it's good it's it's for a cheap movie of
its time
it kind of stands out it's good i always
had kind of an affection for this one
actually i think there's some really
effective like creepy shots in it and
i'm gonna say even though it's
essentially a psycho rip off which i'll
get into it a little bit too but it also
has a little bit of a like a jello
flavor to it yeah also not overtly but
you know just like a little bit now this
this the scenes that happen in it
there's a lot of talking in it and the
scenes are kind of like theatrical it's
like something you'd see in a stage play
but that was just the way movies were in
the 60s a lot of them were like that
it's not an action movie but actually
happens in it yeah it's in a weird
in-between
phase
of of cinema where it's partly theater
partly movie
if you know what i know what i mean yeah
and i mean it's essentially
like it does have some elements of
giallo or slasher movies but it's more
like a gothic murder mystery kind of
reminds me of the old black and white
60s movie about the woman who says that
she sees the ghosts but she's probably
just crazy what was the name of that one
which one carnival is old no but uh the
other one more classic they made we saw
the remake recently it was just like
okay remember the woman shows up she's
taking care of the kids and she thought
the ghosts oh the innocent the innocents
connor in a way reminds me of like like
the innocence
uh the the original innocence just the
way man i loved that movie i thought it
looked way the acting in it kind of was
like that style
but that was like kind of the style that
was the style of the 60s but if you like
the innocence you probably like this if
you like psycho you'd like this yeah i
mean like i said this is obviously like
way cheaper than that and yes yeah and
this is a class and was shot in
eight days
nine days something like that yeah tell
them a story about how they shot well
how they did this this is great so
francis ford coppola now roger corman
even though he's known as like making a
bunch of schlock for as cheaply and as
quickly as possible but entertaining he
actually yeah and most of them i mean
some of his movies are more entertaining
than others but uh most of them are
worth watching james cameron came from
those movies yeah well a lot that's what
i'm saying ron howard like a lot of uh
big directors
started out kind of like under his
tutelage you know what i mean like he
really kind of like knew what he was
like john sales like people like that um
started out working for him and francis
ford coppola was no exception i mean
galaxy of terror was actually the
prototype for aliens
you know and and uh and that's that's
roger corman if you guys have never seen
galaxy of terror see it yeah we did a
review of it not too long ago yeah but
francis ford coppola like i said i think
he directed a couple nudie pictures like
before this i can't remember what they
were called but he had actually um roger
corman was actually in
ireland or you know i think it was
ireland or somewhere in the uk
and they were shooting a movie called
the young racers
now uh coppola was the sound guy on that
movie
now the budget for that movie was 165
000. that was like a bigger movie that
they had but
true to roger corman's nature they
actually had 22 grand left over from the
budget when they were done
so roger corbin goes to coppola and says
hey i'll give you this 22 thousand
dollars i want you to make essentially a
psycho rip-off actually i don't even
think that's what he said i think he
said i want you to make a rip-off of
william castle's homicidal
which itself was a psycho rip-off of a
ripoff that's and yeah that's what
coppola said like because he actually
did um in 2017 when they restored the
movie he actually did um a director's
commentary and he said yeah he
essentially wanted a rip-off of a
rip-off
so we're at the location yeah so they're
already there they like i said he had
the money um so they gave him the 22 000
roger corman did and then
coppola kind of like sneaks around
behind roger corman's back and gets
another 20 000 by selling the european
rights to the movie to like some
production company over there without
telling corman that he had an extra
money so like a man like yeah that's
what he did yeah so he has 42 000 and a
gorgeous like crumbling irish castle to
make this movie in most of the actors
were just you know paid peanuts they
were just like friends of his from ucla
stuff like that and he pretty much
knocked out the script i think he
knocked out like the idea for it like
overnight and like showed it to roger
corman and he told him about the one
scene where like the woman gets killed
coming out of the water like with the
axe and everything yeah and roger
corman's like beautiful film it yeah and
uh he didn't interfere actually the
whole time now he was a free movie
that's what i'm saying yeah i mean
essentially they were going to spend
that 22 000 like on the other movie
anyway like the bigger movie and they
didn't spend it so he's like might as
well get another that was roger corman
that's how he made all those movies
without ever losing a dime was that man
if he ever had anything left over if you
he used like sets and [ __ ] like that
like multiple times because why waste it
you know a big studio 22 grand it's
nothing i mean that
that wouldn't even cover catering no it
probably wouldn't yeah so you know
making a whole movie for forty two
thousand dollars i mean you have to
think too like night of the living dead
which was you know uh you know obviously
like a few years after this was like
five years after this that cost i think
sixty eight thousand yeah maybe slightly
more but this so this was made for forty
two thousand dollars uh like i said he
knocked together the script like really
quick um it does have a lot of
similarities to psycho
in the sense of the character that
you're following from the beginning of
the film spoiler alert she gets killed
like uh probably less than halfway
through the movie which just like in
psycho um so that's kind of similar but
other than that it's kind of more i
don't know like i said it's more like a
gothic it's more gothic because it's set
in a castle and it's more like a murder
mystery i guess more like a murder
history because it's kind of family
intrigue and family yeah which that's
what i mean that's what's it's kind of
like a family curse type thing so what
happens in the story it has slasher
elements yeah and it definitely because
there is an axe murderer like yeah and
women
chained up like raw meat and stuff you
know it's
it's nothing that would shock a modern
audience but
you see i've seen it with modern eyes
look at it that's pretty good for the
60s that's pretty hardcore i mean yeah
like you know it's like something you'd
see in the 70s yeah yeah but black and
white
now i mean so after coppola made it like
i said he didn't really have any um you
know interference from roger corman like
while he was making the movie but then
like after roger corman watched it he
was like it won it needs to be longer uh
he's like it needs another axe murder in
there because he didn't think there was
enough axe murders and another thing
they added which coppola hated and i
guess this was because of the whole
william castle thing we talked about
william castle before when when we
talked about the tingler like all of his
gimmicks
this one also had a gimmick uh it's not
on the one that you watch on 2b but on
the theatrical cut it was they had a
thing at the beginning that i think it
was called the d13 test
and it was basically had this guy
like a little prologue and he was
supposed to be a psychiatrist so i think
it was just an actor but he was just
like supposed to be a psychiatrist and
he's administering a test to the
audience to make sure that you're
mentally sound enough to watch the movie
because it's so terrifying that you know
you might like flip out and like start
ax murdering people if like the movie
like triggers here or something like
that so yeah so they added that which
was like an extra five minutes because
like i said they were trying to like you
know
they were trying to like fill it out
pretty much and i think the and i think
the groundskeeper simon getting beheaded
i think they added that in post too like
they added that after because roger
corman said needs more axe murders you
know what i mean so so they did that but
the groundskeeper murder is still in
there but the prologue at the beginning
with the psychiatrist isn't in there
anymore because um yeah because coppola
really did not like that he's like i
didn't want that added but whatever
so this movie was actually
just made too they were just gonna throw
it on the bottom of because you know how
they used to do double bills like back
in the 50s and 60s
uh this one was gonna be the bottom half
of the double bill but from uh x the man
with x-ray eyes which actually i covered
over my flickers of fear show and that's
like a that's a classic i love that
[ __ ] movie um this one's i don't
think quite as good as that but
it's almost as good as that i'm gonna
say i just i don't know i like that
movie a lot but this one was just kind
of like a throwaway that was gonna be on
the bottom of the bill for that
so the story is kind of about
this woman named louise
and she's apparently married this dude
named john uh who is from a very very
wealthy family at the very beginning
they're in a rowboat just for whatever
reason like a rowboat in the middle of
the night
and they're kind of having an argument
and he's i think she wants a divorce
basically i guess she's like sick of his
ass and he's like well yeah but if you
divorce me then you're not gonna be in
the will like you know you can only get
my family's money like access my
family's money like through me by
remaining married to me
and then very inconveniently uh he has a
heart condition and he uh drops dead
like in the boat
now this is again very inconvenient for
her because
now she's not gonna be able to get the
will because her husband's dead so she's
like well [ __ ] she didn't kill him he
just died accidentally of his condition
so she's like okay well what i'm gonna
do is i'm going to
pretend that he's still alive so she
dumps his ass in the lake or ocean or
whatever the hell and then she writes a
letter to his family in ireland
and i guess they're having a wedding
because like the other brother richard
is marrying his girlfriend or whatever
so she's like oh yeah we're gonna come
to the wedding but i'm gonna come by
myself because john got called away on
business and doesn't know when he'll be
back
and she figures she's like a gold digger
right so she figures when she gets there
that she's gonna like ingratiate herself
into the family so that she gets written
into the will
hopefully before they figure out that
jon is dead you know what i'm saying so
that's kind of her plan
so like i said it's very much a setup
like psycho where you have a woman at
the beginning who has you know committed
a crime and psycho obviously was
embezzling and uh then she kind of gets
killed halfway through but the way that
she starts to ingratiate herself with
the family
now there are two remaining brothers
richard and billy i think is the other
one
and
uh they had a sister named kathleen and
seven years ago kathleen when she was
little she drowned in the pond like on
the uh on the grounds
and the mom uh you know understandably
was inconsolable after this so every
year they have this really weird like
memorial like her grave is all like in
the like right on the grounds like right
outside the house and they have this
whole like ritualistic kind of
more like a funeral like every year like
on the date of her death like
commemorating it and the mom gets like
real emotionally volatile around this
time and they have to bring in the
family doctor and all that kind of stuff
so louise sees this as an opportunity
and she's like i know how i'm gonna
ingratiate myself into this family i'm
gonna say
that
uh kathleen's ghost is walking around
but that she's only talking to me
and you know then i'll be able to give
you messages so she like goes and sneaks
around like into she breaks into
kathleen's room which they've left the
same since the little girl died and she
takes like some of her dolls
and then she ties all the dolls like up
with rope and then she puts like acid or
some slow acting whatever like on it and
then she dives down to the bottom of the
lake
to put these dolls down there so that
the acid will kind of like eat through
the rope and then they'll float up like
it in options so it looks like a sign
like from the ghost or whatever but like
while she's down there she also sees the
super creepy
shrine essentially to the little girl
that looks like the little girl's corpse
is down there but it's in pretty good
shape for being seven years old or you
know the corpse being seven years old so
she's like what the [ __ ] like that's
really creepy like it's a little stone
grave stone like a little thing laying
there and all that kind of stuff so then
she's doing that but then she pops out
the water and somebody pops by and with
an axe and chops her up
and kind of head right off boom well i
don't know if he cut yeah he doesn't cut
her head off because i thought i could i
thought he cut her head off no because
when they find the body later she's
still got her head on the shoulders the
groundskeeper gets his head cut okay
yeah i got to do confused yeah simon the
groundskeeper and i think that guy was
just kind of added for comic relief and
for an extra extra cue axe murder and
maybe as a red herring although you
never do like believe that he's now one
thing i will say about this is that the
mystery there's not a [ __ ] ton of
characters um
so you pretty much know who the axe
murder is i think they
um telegraphed it too
much
you can tell that they're trying to make
you think that richard is the killer
because it's like oh he's more emotion
he's an artist and he's like more
he's not like a jerk but he's more like
aggressive i guess so you know that it's
not him because they're trying to make
you think it's him so really the only
guy that's left well it could be the
doctor i guess because the doctor is
totally acting like a weirdo but again
because he's acting like a weirdo then
you know well that's probably not him
either because it's always going to be
like the least likely person just like
in a giant movie so you know that it's
the more mild-mannered brother billy but
even if even if that wasn't the case you
would still know it was him because they
show like flashbacks of him as a kid and
kathleen as a kid and they're playing
together on the shores of the lake where
she drowned and then him going oh [ __ ]
so you figure oh well he either pushed
her or
feels responsible for her death somehow
and that's probably like what made him
flip out right so i kind of feel like
yeah you know that's coming but yeah
he's the one that's running around like
axe murdering people
so
yeah so i don't know like i really kind
of have
and you find out too that the the body
of kathleen because you see it like
every time somebody gets either killed
and or stalked by the axe murderer
there's that body is always like laying
around somewhere like he's moving it
around from place to place so people
will see it and then it'll he'll be like
chopping people up but you find out
later that it's not her actual
body it's actually like a wax dummy that
he'd made of her that he was like
carrying around yeah but yeah he's
protecting it he's protecting it because
he couldn't protect his actual sister
which said i don't know what right it's
like psycho and him keeping his mom's
body kind of like yeah that's what i
mean so it does have a lot of
similarities weren't really sure if that
was really the body preserved or if it
was just a dummy it was just a dummy
yeah but it was creepy looking it was
very creepy like especially that scene
where louise like dives down with the
dolls and then sees that there she's
like what the [ __ ] and then like she
comes out because that was like a really
good scene i thought
but yeah it's a bad movie but yeah it's
not but you have to understand you have
you have to understand the context of
the time in the context of the time it
was uh it was punching way above its
weight for what they paid for it i mean
it was creepy and you it probably
inspired
more shenanigans later on when it came
to filmmaking remember that old movie
would you know this and that because
you could borrow a lot from this movie
and it ended up in slashers some of the
ideas yeah pretty good yeah pretty good
um
now is this some is this something top
shelf that i would like recommend oh you
gotta go see it no not really there's i
would see other stuff first but if
you've seen a bunch of movies and you're
into horror and you haven't seen this
one yeah you might want to check this
one out i mean i think this is
definitely one of the better psycho
rip-offs yeah and it's not i mean yeah
it's a ripoff in the sense that it's got
a lot of similarities like i said you
have a heroine who gets killed which is
not really the heroine because she's a
shitty person but you know a main
character i guess who gets killed like
less than halfway through the movie like
you think you're gonna be following this
woman the whole time and then poop nope
she gets like axe murdered and then
um you know like you said the whole
thing with the wax dummy like him
carrying the body then and you have a
scene too at the you know the the doctor
played by weird ass patrick mcgee
where he there's a scene at the end
where he like explains you know what i
mean like the pathology of billy like
why he was killing people it's a coppola
movie it's not [ __ ] you know he's he's
put something together
you know they they got more than what
they paid for out of the movie you know
yeah i was actually surprised
particularly the scene where um where
the doctor finds louise's body
like in the what is that like a meat
locker
storage like a meat storage thing and
she's like supposed to be that yeah and
she was like hanging up yeah because
there was like a side of beef or some
[ __ ] over there too but like yeah she
was hanging there and she was like all
bloody and it looked like some of her
skin was scraped off her legs and stuff
like i mean it's black and white so it's
not super graphic but i was like wow
they kind of got away with a lot for
like 1963. yeah kind of let your
imagination run wild with it yeah and
not really sure what it is you're
looking at and i was creepy yeah and i
really liked i really liked like the
underwater shots like where they
especially where like i said where
louise finds the little shrine like
underneath and like some of the
uh scenes like where she goes in the
little girl's room and there's all those
like creepy toys like she's kind of
going around with the thing looking for
toys that she can
use to like pretend that there's a ghost
and stuff like that so it does have a
lot of
you know it does have a lot of
similarities with psycho but it has its
own thing going on like i said it's
almost like a gothic murder mystery
giallo-esque version of psycho
um you know it's with some of the same
plot beats but not really that similar
uh like i said it's definitely one of
the best uh rip i haven't i don't think
i've seen
william castle like i said did one
called homicidal but i think i've seen
it but i was probably like a kid so i
don't remember if that one was it just
borrowed an idea or two from psycho
right yeah the uh the rest of it like
you said it was more like a giallo
murder mystery
slasher kinda yeah yeah it definitely
did have that now it's interesting too
because
i guess you know because psycho came out
in 1960 and that was like such a big
deal and then
immediately like everybody started
making cheapy knockoffs of it and they
all had to have like
like a synonym for crazy but just like
one word like homicidal or now this one
was initially just going to be called
dementia but which you know it in
today's parlance that doesn't really
mean the same thing as crazy but you
know um but i think there was another
movie that was coming out that was
called dementia so they slapped the 13
on the end just because 13 is a scary
number i guess
dementia and 13 don't really have
anything to do with anything
it does it doesn't sound like a band
there is a band called dementia 13.
they're named after this movie actually
but yeah but um yeah so there so there's
more than one movie called dementia but
then you have stuff like an old lady
with a walker
and then well and then like later on in
the 70s you had like the one about uh
that movie about it was like schizoid
like but that was 80s then the one from
the 70s about like ed gain that was
called uh deranged yeah that kind of
stuff so and but that wasn't anything
like psycho that was based on a real
person but i kind of feel like that was
kind of like the naming convention for
these kind of things i don't know i just
i really really had i watched a couple
other reviews of this and some people
dig it but a lot of people kind of
thought it was boring or you know didn't
really i don't know though i always kind
of had an affection for this one um it's
got like some really cool shots it's got
i mean it's very short so you know
there's not like a lot of
i don't know it has like a good plot and
i think like some of the transitions are
a little wonky and stuff like that but
yeah
so a lot of people they would sing
boring because it's kind of wordy
there's got people standing around
having whole conversations
building up because they're not they're
telling they're not showing they can't
really show because yeah they didn't
have any [ __ ] money they didn't have
any money
[Laughter]
but then when it does come when it comes
to the murders they show that or they
show the aftermath of it and it it does
get pretty weird
it could have been shrunk down into a
30-minute twilight zone it probably
would have been more fun but now they're
trying to make a full-length movie
yeah i mean the thing about it is that
i and actually i didn't know this until
i was researching the movie today but
they did a remake of it in 2017
uh and i heard it was kind of [ __ ] i was
gonna watch it like it was on it said it
was on hulu but it was only on hulu if
you had like an one of the add-ons and
i'm like well i'm not paying extra just
to watch that but i read like some other
reviews of it and people said yeah yeah
it just wasn't that great i wouldn't
remake this uh yeah and it's like i
didn't even think i didn't even know it
had been remade this is a one-time thing
and you really only watch it because
it's it's old and it has a lot and it
was ahead of its time in a couple
aspects it had some good ideas in it
it probably influenced other stuff too
wouldn't surprise you if a lot of giallo
flicks ripped this off
italians would look at that goal that's
a good idea well the thing about it
though is that i think technically the
first giallo movie was mario baba's uh
the girl who knew too much which i think
maybe came out the same year as this
okay so
and and giallo movies were actually kind
of based on the giallo murder mysteries
like the books you know what i mean
which had been out since like the 1920s
or something like that um usually edgar
edgar wallace like a lot of british
crime writers so it's not i don't know
it's kind of like i said it's like a
back and forth and in in practice
in in in practical terms though giallo
movies were what they called uh made by
a process called pulled out to ass
they made those things up as they were
going a lot of times they had
the script was just kind of like a
script and then they just would kind of
just film stuff
you know it'd be a good idea we need to
film this and then they'd film some [ __ ]
and then they'd kind of patch it
together into a story that was most of
them
although i will like i said i will argue
that some of them actually do have
really complex plots that absolutely do
work that you would have to
have written ahead of time yeah some of
them but
the good ones were like that
a lot of the average ones that i think
they were just kind of made up after
they were shot and some of them were
based on like i said like stories like
edgar wallace stories like novels like
crime novels some of them were based on
those so if you shoot enough stuff you
can edit it together and make any story
you want it you'll you might have some
continuity but then you might not and it
makes a story i mean there were some of
my remembered i never really could
figure them out
from the 70s what we saw as a kid
yeah well yeah some of that might be
just like lost in translation yeah maybe
this one i kind of feel like this one it
has a kind of like i said a jealous plot
it's more like a gothic plot i think but
kind of there is some overlap um this
story like i said is pretty easy to
follow uh in the sense that you have
this gold digger who's trying to like
suck her way into the family and the
inheritance by pretending that she can
talk to the ghost of this little dead
girl and then she gets killed and then
you know and then they're trying to
figure out like who this axe murder is
that's running around and it's like a
family thing so it's not like a super
complicated plot but like i said it's
not a super long movie either it's only
like a little bit longer than an hour
honestly i think this could have been a
little bit longer like they could have
expanded on the characters some
but
that's okay i mean it's probably always
better like you know to be shorter than
than too long
but i don't know i kind of feel like
they could have like fleshed it out
slightly
i don't know coppola like i said his the
version he wanted uh the director's cut
is 69 minutes
uh and the theatrical cut was 75 minutes
now some of that was the prologue that
he hated so much but some of it like i
said i think the the murder the the
groundskeeper getting her the poacher or
whatever getting um beheaded i think
that was added later just because they
wanted another axe murderer in there
because really louise
other than simon i think was the only
one that got murdered right i mean the
axe murderer did chase other people
around like the mom and stuff but he
didn't catch them i don't remember all
that clearly i remember
some of the stuff i kind of forgot after
i saw it you know to be honest i just
there there were just elements in the
movie that were
ahead of its time for for the 60s yeah i
was like yeah i didn't expect him to do
that you know yeah and i mean if you're
into francis ford coppola and want to
see like some of his early stuff
you know his real rough like cheapy
early stuff i mean he's still like i
said he still has affection for this
movie he did uh you know a restoration
of it and he did like a director's
commentary as recently as 2017
so it does kind of have elements of
giallo movie yeah
it definitely does my favorite jolla was
not a gel it was a fake gel i remember
um alice sweet alice
that was yeah it felt like a giant but i
don't think it was american it was yeah
it was a well you can i mean giallo is a
style yeah most of them are italian but
yeah that is that is kind of it almost
felt like it was dubbed too
yeah i wonder if they did that on
purpose
was it dubbed
i don't know i remember always remember
thinking that that movie was
foreign i always thought it was foreign
until it turned out it was filmed it was
chicago
or something like that something like
that baltimore yeah it might have been
baltimore now yeah thinking about it
yeah we did we we covered that like a
while back yeah i always i look really
really psychopathic little girl turns
out you think she's killing people
and i'm not her though
yeah yeah that's well yeah they make you
kind of think that like i said it's a
red hairing type of thing which they're
kind of doing in this one too but like i
said it's pretty obvious who the killer
is because there's not really that many
people to pick from and
the people that are kind of like acting
shifty you're just kind of like well
it's obviously not them so it must be
the like i said the most innocuous
member of the family because like i said
they telegraph it too much because he
has a couple flashbacks we're just like
oh he's totally the killer but yeah uh
but yeah so if you haven't seen it uh
and you're interested in coppola's early
work then you absolutely should see if
you're interested in 60s horror psycho
rip-offs i definitely think this is one
of the best of the psycho rip-offs of
which there were many uh it's on pluto
tv at the moment it's on 2b you can
probably get it other place as well like
i said it was in the public domain for a
long time most of the
older um versions of it were like real
shitty looking but i've heard that the
restoration like on the special edition
blu-ray is beautiful um but i haven't i
don't think i've seen that one the one
that's on 2b actually looks pretty good
though so you know if you want to watch
it for nothing then you can absolutely
watch it on there and that will do it
for this movie retrospective for this
week and we will see you guys on the
next one bye